dès lors qu'elle est mais désolé mais
dans les enceintes et leurs gardes tu
aimerais dans les eaux était plein
les colocs a pas jusque là bas il faut
pas je sais que fait froid on va tailler
dut cependant garder mais dans les
assiettes et plaît
voilà
[Musique]
moi j'ai fait plus de vingt heures de
patrouille dans un véhicule patrouille
et je ne peux pas compter le nombre de
fois où j'ai répondu à des familles oui
mais l'oeil est rien arrivé je suis
désolé je peux rien faire pour vous mais
ici c'est important pour moi m'ont placé
qu'on l'appelle ouais moi aussi c'est
qu'on l'appelle qu'on lui demande pour
sortir
vous autres domi puis d'eric vous allez
allez côté 6 heures c'est vrai ce que
vous avez vu c'est l'exemple d'un
dossier ont en outre par année seulement
notre service il ya deux ans l'analyse
qu'on en avait fait 7 entre neuf et
douze appels par jour on a raison de
croire que le chef a augmenté parce que
lorsqu'on une question nos patrouilleurs
disent qu'ils en ont davantage
qu'auparavant donc on peut même imaginer
que le chiffre d'adp aux mêmes
conservateur en date d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]